jake mccarthy making his first ever
chase field start they sent him out
there all by himself yeah just you dude
and here comes the rest of the gang
starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
and has pitched well bob in his last two
starts including finally a win in
philadelphia last week yeah really if
you wanted to nitpick it it's just a
matter of too many pitches especially
early in the game the first inning has
been problematic for zach allen
hopefully he can cruise through that
first inning with a low pitch count and
get deeper into the ball game tonight
here's the look in by gallon and the 1-1
pitch to grisham and that's in the air
into left shallow left field backing out
ahmed he calls for it and nick makes the
catch and grissom is retired
and he sends one deep to center field
backs up
[Applause]
that was it right there and that's the
strikeout of danny machado says nestor
ceja good start for zach galland and the
diamondbacks coming up against blake's
now
blake snell is on a roll the 28 year old
making his fourth start against the
diamondbacks this season 25th overall on
the campaign
and there are the season numbers and you
know those numbers can be skewed because
earlier in the season where you had some
rough outings but those numbers are
starting to come down a little bit when
it matters most
fly ball out towards steep center field
beck goes grisham shy of the track will
make the catch ahmed bluffing not going
anywhere as the throw goes to second
chopped right side frazier will go to
second out there on the first safe hill
in the air right side over is frazier on
the short lawn and right he'll make the
catch it ends the inning
it was his 11th home run takes it the
other way this time to left center and
that's going to be one hopper
up and out showing the ground rule
double
hard to third ellis is there
stays put two outs in the second 3-2 to
frazier
right at mick ahmed
glad they reduced it to at least the two
you and me both
swinging a mess and striking out is
paving smith first strikeout of the
night for blake snow
that is right down the middle and that
is strike three at 97 back-to-back case
for snell
and a swing and a miss ends up striking
out the side
in the next pitch to him a little check
swing roller to the right side hosmer is
charging and he's going to take it
himself just in the nick of time
and a swing and a miss and snow makes
quick work of him that's four strikeouts
for blake snell
2-2
and a swing and a miss he will as that
is strikeout number five for blake snell
and machado into center but right at
marta who had him played perfectly
scoots over to right center field and
one pitch one out here on the fourth
back to back free passes issued by zach
gallon here in the fourth inning
one down and that'll bring up austin
nola
driven to deep left center field over
goes martay
and he'll make the catch tagging up at
second moving to third is tatisse
hosmer will also tag and he moves up to
second base so second and third on that
long flyout
to left center field
runners on second and third now with two
outs adam frazier digging in
and that's ball four he has walked him
loaded
third walk issued by zach gallon here in
the fourth inning to load the bases
that'll give jerks and profar an
opportunity to break this 0-0 tie
and the o2 pitch he strike him out
swinging
swinging a miss strikes him out on the
high fastball that strikeout number six
for blake snell
curveball that time and he used it to
strike out kelly that's four strikeouts
in a row for schnell two down in the
fourth inning oh one offering
fly ball left field routine playable for
jerks and now he's going to come in a
little bit harder to get it but he's
able to
squeeze it for the final out and that'll
do it for the diamondbacks here in the
fourth inning
left-handed hitter the first one to him
is skyed left side maybe a play ahead
racing over he's gonna was gonna have a
chance and nick makes a catch
with
his third baseman right next to him one
down
oh zach gallon reaches out and snags
that one off the
bat of trent christian two out single by
jake cronenworth and that'll bring up
manny machado here comes the lumber
driven to deep left field down the line
and that ball is gone
two-run home run for manny machado his
23rd of the year and the padres take a
two-nothing lead zach gallon just hangs
that slider and manny puts it into the
seats
two-nothing padres
swinging a miss and he strikes him out
on a slider
[Applause]
and that is straight three over the
inside corner nine strikeouts for blake
snow back-to-back case here in the fifth
inning
swung on high fly ball to center field
but gent gerson's got a
easy read on it backs up a couple of
steps catches it and that'll do it for
the diamondbacks two out three pass
issued by zach gallon here in the sixth
inning will bring up jerks and profile
first pitch swinging line drive base it
into right field mccarthy is going to
race over for it frazier is going to get
himself over to third base easily the
throw comes in and they're gonna try to
send him here comes the throw home he is
safe at the plate
throw down to second base is going to be
in time to get profile in a rundown
ahmed is chasing him down now he throws
over to walker the first baseman so
profar is retired but some good
aggressive base running by the padres
and adam frazier gets the run across
fly ball right center field over is
grisham to make the
catch blake snell is not allowed to hit
through the first six it's three nothing
san diego
well for the second time tonight the
arizona diamondbacks have loaded the
bases via the walk
this time caleb smith will have to get
past eric hosmer
and a little ground ball to first
walker's got it and he will beat hosmer
to the bag to win the inning and he
starts this seventh inning without
having allowed a hit in tonight's game
fly ball to shallow right east coming in
on a slant will make the catch for the
first out of the seventh inning
2-2 pitch swinging a miss strike three
10th strikeout of the evening for blake
snell and two down here in the seventh
fly ball
into left field here comes profar to
make the catch
snellzilla's got it going on in the
desert tonight he's not allowed to hit
through the first seven innings well in
between innings after blake snell came
off he got congratulations from his
teammates and his manager and he is done
for the night inserting parole at the
end of the game the signal to tony
randazzo david at 2 59 with six home
runs
there's a little bloop this has a chance
and peralta wrecks it with one out in
the eighth inning breaks up the no
hitters carson at second christian at
first 1-2-1 pavon smith stage is set
he stuck him out in the padres win the
tying run did come to the plate but a
shutout for the padres tonight
[Applause]
you